thank you
hey you are you wasting your time on
social media again your brothers and
sisters in the slam nap from Norway are
establishing a Masjid a dawa Center
establishing a Masjid to convey The
Message of Islam is one of the best
Deeds a Muslim can do there's a huge
need for it in Norway you know this and
I know this so that makes the Lord even
greater so give generously and Allah
azzawajal give you even more
we have some shocking updates about the
Quran burner phenomena in Scandinavia
but first let's watch this video and
then I'll comment on what happened after
that
subhanallah brothers and sisters look at
this this Quran first and foremost he's
one of the three Quran burners in Norway
you have this main guy fortune and you
have his Sideshow Bobs and he's one of
those Sideshow bobs so look at him and
he's burning the Quran and he's trying
to extinguish the light of Allah by
blowing at it and the ashes just falls
back on his face
what a symbolic incident subhanallah
Allah says in the Quran
they want to extinguish the light of
Allah with their mouths
but Allah refuses except to perfect his
light even though the disbelievers they
hate it
so what happened to this person
subhanallah
recently read that he committed suicide
now look at this an individual
is burning the Quran to express all of
this emotions and his hatred towards
Islam Muslims
but deep down inside he's so empty he
doesn't have any purpose in life except
to spread hatred against Islam and
Muslims
so he feels so depressed that he doesn't
feel the life is worth living
now this is a scandal brothers and
sisters this is a huge scandal
we don't want people taking their own
life because they don't have the
guidance of Allah
what we wish for people is that they
find the truth of Islam so what we
should do is to make Dua for these
people as the prophet salallahu alaihi
wasallam made for honorable when he was
one of the staunchest enemies towards
Islam and then Allah
changed his heart
and he became one of the greatest of the
companions
we are establishing a mega mosque and
Tower Center in the country of Norway
and insha Allah with this Center we aim
to Enlighten the Norwegian people with
The Message of Islam and the message of
the Quran so brothers and sisters we
should be taking positive action instead
of just reaction so instead of just
reacting to this Quran banner and not
doing anything constructive or
productive we should be making donations
in sadaka for the sake of Allah to
establish this Mega mosque so we can
eradicate this hatred so no more people
will commit suicide and that these
people Insha'Allah find the truth of
Islam Muhammad hijab may Allah preserve
him has already raised more than 125
000 with his two last videos about the
Quran incident and we want to read 200
thousand dollars Insha'Allah with your
help and support and brothers and
sisters remember whenever you give for
the sake of Allah to establish a Masjid
the prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam
has promised that Allah will build a
house for you in Paradise
now what more do we need than that if we
can attain Paradise if you have one foot
inside Paradise alhamdulillah you have
achieved it all and Allah will build a
house for you in Jannah so click the
link let's take action and Enlighten the
people of Norway with the message of the
Quran
the prophet Muhammad
sallam told us
when the son of Adam dies all of his
Good Deeds are interrupted they are
finished except for three things
a continuous charity and a beneficial
knowledge and also a righteous offspring
that makes Dwight for him your brothers
and sisters in Islam net from Norway are
establishing a Masjid a dawah center and
fulfilling a great portion of this
Hadith on your behalf establishing a
Masjid to convey The Message of Islam is
one of the best Deeds a Muslim can do
whenever someone prays there whenever
someone gives shahada in the Masjid
whenever someone learns something in the
Masjid yes that will be something that
you'll have on your scale so give
generously and Allah azzawajal give you
[Music]